we're gonna make less money this year at
a hundred million that we made last year
at sixty seven net I don't mean
percentage net meaning they're in
trouble I see it which means I over
invested more people more capabilities
because I'm gonna take the whole [ __ ]
pie so you know what I mean like I'm not
worried about how much cash I'm gonna
take home in 2016 because I can take a
lot more in 2020 then I you know it's
much more fun to take home 44 million in
2020 than 3 million in 2017 18 and 19
instead of 4 million in 20 people are 99
percent of the market is shorter and the
1 percent that isn't and has the talent
wins every time which makes no sense
because unless you're gonna die you
should only play long-term there was a
stat that some dude in Mexico City said
one of these life futurist type of
characters I'm sure he's more have no
idea who so I just but he was right
before me as I was miked up and he says
it's been scientifically proven so I
don't know if it has or not because I've
learned to take that with a grain of
salt but that 85% of what humans make
decisions about is irrational and that
spoke to me because a I think it's
higher and B it's why I think all my
success is happening I am stunningly the
most rational and the most practical of
all yet I don't seem it and it when he
said in like right that's why because
the rest of the market is irrational yes
Tom so for me my mom credit golf for me
tears down a job for me unless you know
these demons draw for me
no even iPhone for me I don't mind
stressing who got a rock for me good for
me what's good for me I'm trying to die
a little faster I was trying to see them
green pastures